welcome to Hari subbies the channel
where we discussed the latest tech news
and delve into newest tech products so
recently Andy has really been taking the
lead on the mainstream platform with
their new 2000 series however now aim'd
is starting to accentuate their lead in
the enthusiast platform as well which
can be seen in their view review of
their thread ripper series which has 32
cores and 64 threads but before we get
into make sure to hit that subscribe
button if you guys like to stay updated
with the latest tech news related to
gaming and pcs well as you guys already
probably heard Intel just unveiled their
28th core 56 thread enthusiast line CPU
and it was overclocked all the way to 5
ki hurts at first while this seemed
really impressive after the initial hype
surrounding it faded off and there's
more details about it it actually wasn't
as impressive as it first seemed so what
happened while taking a closer look this
CPU fits long with the 3647 LG's socket
and its motherboard has 6 DIMM slots on
either side it's all fine until you
realize that the motherboard also has 4
8 pin EPS power connectors and this
processor requires a very high 1000
watts in order to completely fulfill its
power requirement needs also that's not
it Intel was actually using a 1000 watt
liquid cooler in order to be able to
achieve those high frequencies of 5
gigahertz so clearly it isn't as
impressive as it first seemed right now
this CPU just seems like the Xeon
Platinum 8180 with an unlocked
multiplier also some other bad news is
that Xeon processor already costs
$10,000 so who knows how much Intel will
charge for this new enthusiast one that
can overclock as well as a result even
though this chip may perform really well
it once again is super expensive and
draws a lot of power on top of that and
so it really doesn't make sense
even for extreme enthusiasts to buy this
chip so that's intel's side of the into
this line so what does AMD have to offer
well recently AMD also revealed a new
flagship processor which will most
likely be called the 2950 x4 the next
thread Ripper series and this CPU is
going to have 32 cores and 64 threads
and that is even for more coarse than
what Intel has to offer so straight off
the bat Ami's taking the core lead on
top of this AMD is also coming out with
an others chip which will most likely be
called the 29 20 X which will have 24
cores and 48 threads so as for right now
those are the two models that AMD has
revealed for their next Red River series
well
what about performance do these AMD CPUs
also get up to 5 gigahertz like the
Intel one well maybe they could if they
had a 1000 watt cooler but on a bit more
serious note the base frequency for
these new chips will be 3 gigahertz and
their max turbo frequency will be 3
point 4 gigahertz
these are just the numbers that AMD has
given us right now and AMD themselves
have said that it may fluctuate so it
may go up or down a tiny bit so make
sure to keep that in mind on top of this
the TDP of the chip is only 250 watts
which is actually really impressive for
32 cores 64 threads GPU another benefit
is that AMD is keeping to their promise
and these new CPUs will also work with
the last generation motherboards which
are the x3 99 and AMD is bringing these
new thread Ripper CPUs on to the 7
animator process while Intel is still
struggling to bring it on to the 10
nanometer process and they're even
delaying that even more so once again
AMD is taking the lead next up how much
are these CPE is going to cost
well AMD didn't drop any hints about the
price however if you look at it from a
relative scale from last generation and
its core count and at this generation
its core count for example the flagship
last generation which was the 1950 X had
16 cores and 32 threads and it cost a
$1000 so this time we have a double
amount of cores and double amount of
threads and so it should cost $2,000
for the 2950 X and the 2920 ax should
cost $1600
but that's just looking at it on a
relative standpoint AMD may choose to
charge more or less than that but
probably less because AMD is known for
the value now considering that into's
flagship cpu right now is 18 cores and
32 6 threads for $2000 you're getting an
additional 14 cores and 28 threads for
the same price or maybe even less from
AMD so as you guys can all see the new
thread Ripper series is an absolute
steal from AMD finally what are these
new CPUs coming out well we can expect
these new CPUs to come out at the same
time that try to be launched last year
so in August so as you guys can see even
though Intel may have the advantage in
core clock even on the enthusiast line
aim just simply bringing so much value
for such a good price that AMD is
definitely the clear choice for most
people and so as you guys can see ambe's
not only taking over the main stream
platform but the enthusiast one as well
so how do you guys feel about this do
you guys think that the 32 or 64 thread
CPU is completely pointless and no one
is ever gonna use all of it so it
doesn't really matter or are you happy
that AMD is bringing so much competition
and bringing more value to the market
make sure to comment down below what you
guys think because I do read all my
comments and I'm curious as to what you
guys think so make sure to post your
thoughts also if you guys like this
video then make sure drop a like and hit
that subscribe button if you guys would
like to see more videos just like this
one but until next time bye
[Music]